with recent TV I'm here at the Sundance
Film Festival in Park City Utah this
doctrine is speaking with the most
famous flag burner in America
he's the Johnson in Texas versus Johnson
and he's featured in a new documentary
about the controversial Attorney William
Kunstler my name is Gregory Joey is my
nickname Johnson and I was a defendant
in Texas versus Johnson the US Supreme
Court case for burning the American flag
I was in a protest in Dallas Texas in
1984 when Reagan was being read
nominated for his second term as
American president they had a Nuremberg
type rally in Dallas to promote that and
it was a very spirited and intense
protest outside the convention center
and the city really was draped in
American flags like Nuremberg for during
the Nazi period and I think there's a
similar political purpose in mind you
know these conventions are very
choreographed so we burned the flag as a
form of protest and I got arrested and I
got charged with desecration of a
venerated object burning the American
flag and I got I got convicted and
sentenced to a year in jail and a $2,000
fine and I got out on appeal fortunately
and but then went on a four-year five
year legal battle until 1989 when it
went before the Supreme Court and I sent
a telegram to William Kunstler
who's the subject of this film William
Kunstler disturbing the universe I sent
a telegram to him from Texas in 1988
saying that this is a very serious case
I'm sure you've heard about in the news
and I said that I thought something of
this magnitude required someone of his
history and stature so and he phoned me
the next day and said that you would be
you know proud to represent me
and the case is about compulsory
patriotism enforce patriotism which is
still very much a question today I mean
you can't be a presidential candidate
without wearing a flag on your lapel or
you can't be a high school or college
athlete without putting the flag on your
on your jersey it's a whole atmosphere
around the support the troops support
the war on terror well I think people
like in this society you know are
trained in that kind of unquestioning
you know blind obedience ignorance is is
is ignorance about what the Empire is
actually done to people across the
planet so I'm not really surprised I
think that's part of the responsibility
of you know challenging people's
prejudices and their biases and and
there's a whole planet of humanity out
there you know billions of people who
are like brutally exploited are starving
for absolutely no reason except that
there's no profit in helping them for
for the Empire for imperialism for
capitalism and that that's what I think
we need that's what humanity needs to be
on and move beyond you know and so you
know it's not really it's not really my
fault that they react that way it's the
way they've been indoctrinated well that
was asked to be interviewed by the
counselor daughters we Sarah and Emily
counselor and I was proud to be involved
I was very honored and it's an
incredible film you know William
Kunstler was a phenomenal human being he
had tremendous passion you know it was a
huge fire in his soul to represent
people that have been deemed pariahs by
society I think it's really I think it's
beautiful I hope it instills and
everybody who sees it this sense of
passion about we need to we need to take
responsibility for changing the world
it's not it's not gonna come through
Obama you know I'll be the dissident
voice around that Obama is gonna be
commander in chief for US imperialism
and that's why he has nothing to say
about these horrible crimes that the
us-backed Israeli massacre going on in
in Gaza right now I think it's inspiring
that there's artists here trying to
create art that liberates you know and
and in the whole society people need to
be doing this kind of thing but
ultimately I think we need a revolution
the whole system of imperialism needs to
be uprooted you know and the whole Rhian
visioning of revolution and communism
yeah the kind of communism that Bob
Avakian is envisioning where dissent
just wouldn't be tolerated but would see
be seen as absolutely vital you know
that kind of a vibrant atmosphere that
kind of ferment you know politically it
ideologically artistically you know
broadly in society people debating
questions and and you know that's
absolutely critical towards towards
moving humanity you know beyond all the
ignorance